st claire shores michigan a summer
resort community about 40 minutes from
detroit located on prime real estate is
jax a lakeside restaurant recently
acquired by three bodybuilders bill
scott and tammer
let's do it scott and matt don't scott
at the gym easy get it we all work out
together and hang out together all of us
are partners in the restaurant
jax is known for having great
entertainment
[Music]
being the resort style place to come to
it's like girls gone wild across the
whole lake winter time
[Music]
there isn't much going on
jax has had a reputation for bad food i
don't think i'd order it again
and so that's really in my opinion
that's what killed us we really
got to fix this we brought aj in to run
the kitchen here's the revise aj is
tamer's father no that's your table
that's your kebab i don't see the fish
and chips man no you don't understand we
put all this trust in him oh never mind
the kitchen has completely fallen apart
it's got to stop it's got to stop so we
put him in the front of the house to act
as the general manager just so we don't
have to fire him because that is my
partner's father
can i help you with something i'll be
talking to the customers flirting with
the ladies and asking about the food in
between
on a business level i can't stand a man
every night during hours he gets wasted
he gets so drunk bring it on
uzo is my favorite drink i like the
drink oozo
we all gonna have music tonight
[Music]
to me it's that professional
it's a nice life
i like it
[Music]
then i'm going to take them out and beat
up scott he's dangerous he can hurt you
if he wants to hurt you
people are terrified of him no no one
minute late i'm telling you a c
started getting calls from customers
saying he scares everybody away
so tamara and i had to make a decision
to remove him
from the restaurant unbelievable he's a
silent partner now i'm about to have a
nervous breakdown a total mess we got
aaron in to replace my father in the
kitchen i'm looking for 53 calamari
let's go i had only been here seven
weeks and the whole ball of wax was uh
was was messed up
i'm smelling fire
i knew there had to be some changes but
i wasn't gonna be allowed to make them
because the owner's really happy with
the menu
it's just unfortunate that we have to
take money from other avenues to try to
make the place survive i'm the one that
has the most investment i have
almost a half a million dollars invested
if we're about to lose this business i
can't recover
scott feels that we are running the
business into the ground and he's losing
all of his money we owe fairway eleven
thousand dollars i mean we owe back
sales taxes we owe back payroll taxes
when you start getting to owing the
government money then you know that's an
issue if things don't change i don't
know how to make the place survive
[Music]
taking advantage of the frozen lake
gordon snowmobiles his way to jacks
wow absolutely amazing this restaurant
is centrally located at the heart of
five great lakes but they're in trouble
i don't know why and i'm about to find
out
unbelievable jacks
wow what a place
nice to see you nice to have you gordon
come on in i'm actually not nervous but
i hope he loves the food of course
um aj so you're the owner no
but scott is here and they are here yes
and scott is the bouncer no why are you
standing there looking for a fight
come over here that's the way he's
standing how are you doing
how are you doing good good nice to see
you nice to see you too are you in
training or what i've been training 24
years extraordinary are they real or
so you're the owner i'm one of the
owners i got his son is another one
aren't you i'm tamara he'll be in this
afternoon okay good and there's one more
somewhere
nice to meet you another gym
nice to meet you yeah
after meeting two owners and a general
manager gordon decides to talk to each
of them individually so that they can be
totally honest about the problems at
jacks now what kind of hours you put in
65 a week and scott put 65 in
no
we had to move him out of the restaurant
he was scaring my employees
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
why was scott pushed out because he's
lost a ton of customers because of the
things that he did we got complaints
complaints and complaints
why would you scare customers away you
know i'm not sure maybe because i was
intense you know but i want to be more
involved
what's the problem with the restaurant
we have terrible food
what's the problem with the restaurant i
personally don't see a problem with the
business it's really good
okay
um
what's the problem with the restaurants
aj
what's he drinking
you know he drinks oozo all the time you
just turn around and drink a quick shot
that's what he does he makes a hundred
thousand dollars a year 100 grand yes
ridiculous
oh my god three individuals three
completely different stories i haven't
even tasted the food yet where'd you
start oh my god
okay here we go
hmm
right
nice to see without eric it's really
important for me to see as much as
possible i would try this omelette here
oh it's crabs just split with a cake
it looks like crap
oh crap omelettes
i'll definitely take one of the uh k on
this okay i'm gonna go after that for
the uh honey pecan salmon okay and then
um good old-fashioned fish and chips oh
good yeah thanks
excellent
[Music]
you just sat there staring at me
like some big muscle head meatball
[ __ ] me
aaron what why do you swallow your crab
with a k on the ground because it's not
wrist mock crab me
i didn't want anybody to get the
misconception it's artificial
guarantee no complaints on this
guaranteed
that's a pretty bold statement
excellent thank you my darling wow look
at the size of that that's a lot of crap
and you haven't told me about the k yet
oh he said he wanted everybody to know
that it wasn't real crab it's artificial
crab so he spelled it with a case so
there was no misconception so it's fake
crab meat
in the seafood restaurant on the water
[Music]
oh [ __ ] me
holy crap rubber tasteless that's going
straight to the trash
oh my god
he hated it why
the fake crab was the number one reason
the omelette didn't go over well doesn't
like the crab in there i i've never that
was already here i didn't buy that stuff
i don't want to use frozen fish it's not
product that i'm absolutely overly proud
of but at the same point i'm held
accountable for all the inventory that
the owners have paid for how's the food
so far
why are we serving fake crabbing anomaly
i don't
you did that
you're the general manager
why'd you laugh i give the choice have
you been drinking no
the crab was shocking embarrassing and
fake it tastes disgusting have you
tasted that crap no i'm extremely
allergic
to crab and shrimp so i can't believe it
there's nothing crab in there
i understand it's monkey fish oh my god
i'll let you finish your meal
general manager my ass
i'm being blamed he thinks that ashley
did allow him to do that before letting
him serve those types of crashes because
it's great cram aj's the general manager
he's supposed to oversee the food and
now i'm hoping and praying that gordon
says aj is the one that's bleeding his
business
okay fish and chips
certainly the best looking thing i've
seen
somebody rubbery is it frozen the fish i
believe it's frozen it is frozen when
you take a bite of that cod it's
almost like you've got a breaded condom
in your mouth
he said it was rubbery uh too greasy and
it just said it tasted like a frozen
cotton obviously he hit it right on the
button so this is the same recipe that
we've used here forever so i am for
change i want to change good
[Music]
wow this one is the
salmon
look at that
thank you sweet
[Music]
damn
everything's just so sweet
the
dressing is like honey and so much of it
absolutely disgusting
quite possibly one of the worst salmon
dishes i've ever eaten
it's a pretty successful opinion though
after one of the worst meals he's ever
had this is chef aaron
gordon begins to explore how this
perfectly situated seafood restaurant
can serve such dreadful food that was
horrendous why are you serving fake crab
meat it's inventory that we have have
you tasted that it's plain there's
nothing to it it's just disgusting
plastic it's exactly what it is the
salmon dish that was shipped at its best
sweet on sweet on sweet and sweet that's
actually one of the top sellers that's
why the place has got such a [ __ ]
reputation for crap food
it's still not clear who's in charge of
the food he's in charge of food
it's not true i have no control
i follow you guys being thrown under the
bus because all the recipes and the
things that he didn't enjoy are things
that were set in place before i even got
here who's controlling the [ __ ] menu
the owners are
scott
is that what you wanted here not at all
i don't have nothing to do with food
what aj i want answers there are
certainties are not under my control
you're the general manager i tried not
to have it go on but i get overruled
aj has many excuses and never wants to
own up to his faults it's terrible aj
it's got to be your responsibility no
law
[Music]
with no one taking responsibility for
any of the problems gordon knows the
best way to get any answers is to
observe tonight's dinner service okay
how would you like that cooked
all right it's our first order we got
tables tamara how are you doing brother
after working a full day at his other
job good to meet you nice to meet you
tamara the restaurant's third partner
arrives let me ask you straight out what
do you think is wrong with the
restaurant the food's like hitting this
it's inconsistent yeah and forget the
father figure now but isn't aj
responsible for the food and beverage in
terms of running the restaurant and the
kitchen yes
every time i asked aj to what was going
on he was blaming the owners
i do have the most difficult position
being here i'm working with my friends
and my father who is my family and that
makes everything very difficult it sucks
i'm gonna have a look around spend time
in the kitchen the dyeing room chef it's
good to meet you yeah livewise finally
this rice has issues
take this out and at least try to stir
it up or something you brought it up man
i gotta move it there's not enough depth
in our kitchen yeah i got a big chunk
here too what the [ __ ] man they've been
set in their ways
i don't know that they want to conform
to a change do we have any rice yet nope
i threw it out oh my god
with a clear lack of support in the
kitchen i'm [ __ ] here aaron has yet to
send out the first wave of orders
so it's christmas
my lead is table 11.
they don't have any food if it doesn't
come in 15 minutes
15 minutes
here's a big blue fillet
up top
45 minutes into the dinner service and
food is finally beginning to leave the
kitchen
[Music]
keep it going 64 calamari i'll take it
anytime as the dishes get rushed to the
dining room
customers are receiving food that's not
exactly the way they ordered it we gotta
send this back what's wrong with that
it's supposed to be uh well done and
it's rare
and well done steak is the easiest steak
in the world to cook
nearby we need this medium on the fly it
was overcooked there were the cheeses
she said she said it's terrible she
didn't like it i needed chicken alfredo
on the fly i hate that okay he wants
this under the heat for read it here
dude we're weeded here
i've never seen frozen food so [ __ ]
complicated
unbelievable an absolute meltdown not
just in the kitchen but the dining room
as well just under 20 dishes have come
back and more frustratingly it's frozen
food they can't even cook that right
unbelievable
[Music]
where'd your dad go i don't know
[Music]
aj's gonna have to get back up where is
he
[Music]
aj is a general manager here now and he
needs to be overseeing the restaurant
we won't probably be coming back here
the food was wrong
we're gonna take care of this and then
you know please come back because it's
only going to get better
i don't know now just cop it buy them
around on me okay so much money lost you
guys i'm getting i'm giving away every
damn meal that i have tonight everything
i'm giving away free
[Music]
honest to god the last hour everything
we gave away is free
oh my god can i get any worse
i'm watching food get thrown away in the
garbage can that's my money going out
the window it's just a disappointment i
let it go on this long
[Music]
after a chaotic dinner service with
numerous dishes coming back and comp
food gordon confronts the owners with an
important question that has yet to be
answered who has the final say at jax
we haven't come to an agreement on that
we've only been in the business for one
year aj he's been in the business for 40
years and we were relying on that to
drive us to where we needed to be and he
has let us down
that's the truth that's what it is right
so
that's a tough spot for you yes my dad
has made many mistakes here but my
partners need to step up and understand
he's my father and that makes everything
very difficult you have to separate the
father son
nothing to do with business
you have to let go
that's the first and foremost crucial
thing in this [ __ ] restaurant
understandable i think aj is the main
reasons why this business is extremely
in whole and he's still taking his damn
check every damn week
we
aj you're the one that makes all the
money not us you know yeah how many
hours are we got that doesn't matter i
put the money up not for you to lose it
i put it up because aj was supposed to
be a 40-year restaurant let me say
something i booked eight parties big
parties by thousands of dollars and
that's the thankfulness i get from this
man he's acting like a child you know be
a man face up story after story after
story after story i'm so sick of it
i'm pissed
[Music]
there's so much food coming back last
night that's not normal in any
restaurant so i decided to get in early
this morning have a good look around for
any member of the staff come in
[Music]
that is salmon that's just marinaded in
it's like
an italian dressing oh dear what's this
oh seafood restaurant on the water
tuna and dyed pink to make it look
authentic look at it my god
unbelievable and here we have
that looks like the mushroom risotto
great risotto unbelievable
[Music]
alarmed by the state of the kitchen
gordon is anxious to take the staff on a
tour good morning there's something i
want to show you guys yeah
come with me
come in
the general hygiene in this fridge is a
[ __ ] joke all right come round
walking around want to get up to speed
look at the ingredients check him what
is that
is that just taken from the steam table
and dumped on the trolley and then
whisked it in that's exactly what it is
that should be straight in the trash
hey i ate here yesterday yeah i'm not
happy
whoever's responsible
40 years in the business well
experienced
you have to seriously start opening your
eyes this place is not right here we've
got no chance i did not know that was
going on item after items oh i was
pissed what's this here i believe it's
beef tips beef bets in blood that's
nasty i need some answers aj it's pretty
terrible and you know a lot of it lies
on aj there's no excuse for it and
that's the that's the classic of the day
that ladies and gentlemen is a risotto
take a good look unfortunately it's not
a drawing
that's real
serious [ __ ] at his best it's a joke
look at the [ __ ] collar of the
chicken aj can i have a look at it yeah
you've got to see it aj i do see it
my father doesn't want to deal with the
back vowels the back house is falling
apart that's my frustration
i'm sorry but it's not right
it's got to be somebody's responsibility
i'm not going to take responsibility
it's the owner's fault what would i
blame myself for that i'm not going to
live for that unbelievable
trusting my dad
is obviously not working look at where
all our money is gone i'm really mad
right now
they can't go on like this get everyone
together we're gonna just get everything
cleaned up start scrubbing walls
cleaning all the stoves get rid of all
that food in there whatever's dirty
garbage
while the staff and owners clean the
kitchen chef ramsay meets with local
fishermen how are you what's your
meeting to see what jax is not taking
advantage of just outside its doors
fresh fish the ice is what a foot deep
ah this is actually about nine inches
the size of that tiny little rod yeah
i'll try it a couple times you might get
something on there that attracts them my
god if you feel something then you pull
it up
perch i mean very tasty oh very tasty do
you ever get into jacks to eat yes oh
yes i do what's the food like in there i
don't like their fish so much because
they use a little bit too much sauces
and you kind of lose the actual flavor
of the real fish you know yeah got
something on there i think you got a
fish pull it pull it pull it up yeah it
is on yeah oh yeah there you go you got
one very good very good very good
it's just nasty
it is nasty and i've had people tell me
when i eat at your restaurant i get sick
and i start laughing thinking oh they're
just full of [ __ ] they're not they do
get sick gross this is [ __ ] up
oh my god
god look at them hey not bad cash today
fantastic now i'm going to um turn this
into a really nice chowder okay once you
guys have finished you're gonna come
over have a bowl absolutely hey thank
you very much get those pleasures let
your hands warm see you later
[Music]
after an informative afternoon with the
locals chef ramsay introduces the first
of many changes designed to get jacks
back on track you
and you and i are gonna go make a
chowder i'm gonna serve it in a bread
basket something simple finished fresh
local caught fish
let's go
i'm pretty excited to prepare this food
i i think that listen some of these
changes are going to be what does it for
us start off with touch of olive oil
bacon onions celery with a touch of
tabasco oh my gosh i'm standing here
next to chef ramsay he's showing me food
that he likes and he thinks will work
you better take advantage of it that's
all i can think of right a really nice
chowder yeah
i'm gonna do a little poached salmon as
well so salmon in three or four minutes
in there the whole thing has to ooze
fresh
out of the core bouillon
your broth
over
two easy dishes to make the pressure
less
on the line i'm excited yeah i hope you
are
with the special set gordon decides to
implement one other change to the dinner
service scott
you said you want to be more involved
tonight run a section
present a menu welcome them hand over
take the order push the specials and
serve
scott he's gonna get beat up really bad
tonight i'd like to laugh at him a
little bit
he's gonna be running your section
tonight give him your apron yeah i think
we've got enough string to go around um
yeah prove that you're not some scary
monster that wants to beat the crap out
of everybody does that large egg have a
smile or not sure give us one yeah
oh [ __ ] it now okay
yeah good luck push your specials excite
them don't scare them
with customers starting to arrive
scott is embracing being a waiter
the kitchen seems ready with the new
specials i'll keep my eye in the window
and communicate with you and everyone
seems ready to make tonight's service a
success i believe we have balsamic or
vinegar we would prefer balsamic if we
if i don't have you know bear with me if
we don't have balsamic is raspberry okay
okay how's he doing he's doing good he's
doing that you're watching he's doing
great why is his head all tilted like
that
i don't know what happened i have
everything right after you guys thank
you
roly-poly look at chimpanzee hanging
over a cage looking for something else
[Music]
it's a half hour into dinner service and
the new fresh seafood specials are a
popular choice i'm gonna have a boat
saying fish chowder
as the tickets pile in three special
salmon and a chowder the challenge now
is getting the food out god i need those
special salmon gulo special what
i'd call for stuff and they'd be not
listening to my organization and what i
wanted to have come up to the hot plate
one piece of salmon did you season it
with salt like i said oh [ __ ] eat it i
need it yesterday get it done
not one table come out of this kitchen
completed yet
[Music]
[ __ ] it
come on it's so frustrating looking at
the cooks behind the line because they
don't actually give a damn
so aaron's got his work cut out and he
can't work with that dead wood no chance
with aaron's orders falling on deaf ears
i'm dying dying for those alfredo's very
little food has left the kitchen where's
our food we haven't waited
45 minutes to an hour for our food
shaking that's
getting bad getting momentum calm down
look you guys it didn't say cheese on
the ticket i can't have cheese on the
burger what are we gonna do we gotta fix
this i don't know nothing
well they're waiting forever for this
food beyond it i i don't know
about time they start showing the guy a
little bit of respect
but they're not
tell me that one day it's just rude i
need a new bun for this kid burger
please
anton give me a new bun on now aaron
look at me he's got to do it yeah you
can't mop up for them can we run that
come right back for that kid burger
please
[Music]
the place is going down in flames
the tickets are backed up nothing's
coming out it turned into a total
disaster
an hour into dinner service
virtually no food has left the kitchen
my god and aaron who's only been working
at the restaurant for a matter of weeks
just toast me a croissant i need it
yesterday i don't know what that is
now faces the prospect of running the
kitchen alone
why do my items take so long there's too
much of a headphone here i want to talk
to you about it seriously to get it
[ __ ] right and each every one of you
have to step up to the mark this ration
hasn't got long to go unless we change
we're changing with or without you so do
as a chef says and listen okay it was
good that chef ramsay came in and kicked
them between the legs and mate said hey
get your [ __ ] together or get out you
got 84 coming my way right grill fry
okay
good burger no cheese
finally okay special salmon panko perch
up top 84 up top good
food is finally coming out of the
kitchen
and scott is finally getting comfortable
as a waiter i get not anything out of
your way guys although diners are
enjoying the new seafood specials how's
the fresh perch great yes
the rest of the menu is a disaster i
need this a little bit more
that's not meant well
the complaint's gonna go straight back
to the kitchen whoever's cooking
shrimp's over cooking it they've gotta
know before service do we tell them
after the next dish is gonna be
overcooked as well it could be done
straight away okay yeah customer can
wait
aj when they're in a crunch in the
kitchen aj sometimes gets confused aj
hey jay who's calling me
of course we laugh because he waddles
away but
at the end of the day it's really not
funny the kitchen needs to know first my
friend then they stop [ __ ]
overcooking it that's your job we got a
complaint on the shrimp aaron listen
listen we got a complaint on the shrimp
series poorly cooked food or it was
under cooked food or they weren't happy
with the food we lost it we lost control
is that ready this is not ready
no this is not ready come on big boy
sick of this [ __ ] we're going down
quicker than the titanic
they get better service
at a shelter than they do here
what the [ __ ] dude
i don't know everything was screwed up
give it to me again without all the
grease in the bottom food got screwed up
i need the whole sandwich we made but
pissed off
[Music]
with yet another meltdown in the kitchen
chef ramsay knows drastic changes are
needed aaron
there's no one behind there that respect
you enough as the head chef and you need
to stamp your authority on that kitchen
i mean a joke it is a joke you're not an
[ __ ] for your staff
they're there to support you
and i'm more
[ __ ] off with you aj because you pass
it to him if this was my
restaurant
your salary will be cut by 50
half your salary can benefit crucial
areas that need supporting right now
that's a big thing he is the motivation
for me being here so cutting my dad's
salary that's not a simple thing to do
and i'm not a heartless
cold-hearted person
tomorrow there's gonna be major changes
we're relaunching this place
and i am gonna have them crammed in here
like [ __ ] sardines
in order to be ready for the relaunch
gordon's team works all night to make
jax a more inviting seafood restaurant
now all night we've been working yeah
we've made some really nice exciting
subtle changes it's beautiful let's go
let's go i'll check it out
very cool that's awesome this is sweet
something
that's not which i can't believe you've
never had in here i know fun for the
kids yes a wonderful fish tank
of course what do you think the boys in
the ceiling those are great
so simple but cool oh yes look at that
look at the metal we've got the
wool
lined with corrugated iron so it just
modernizes it up
freshens it up
looks so nice and no more faded wood
i hated those walls before nice little
fresh fish tanks on the wall yes oh
there's a little fish in there we've got
the little fish tanks along the wall as
well just so when you set in those
booths you can have some fun
that is great i was like wow especially
because i thought the only answer this
place was a bulldozer
it's incredible how he took something so
simple
and made it so warm and inviting it's
great thank you so
you're much wondering why the rope is on
the table yes
this is the new menu yes wow yeah and on
the back of the menu right now you can
have some fun with the knots that is so
cool okay give the kitchen a touch of
time when we get backed up how fun yes
that's awesome so cool
chef ramsay took it real simple he took
a nautical thing we had he ran with it
and some simple nice light touches and
it's great i love what he did here it's
warm it feels friendly
i love it thank you
now that the decor has been freshened up
gordon introduces the most critical
change for this restaurant a new menu
fresh mussels crab cakes fresh oysters
the fish tacos yeah nice post salmon
exactly like last night fresh delicious
i'm glad the whole menu's gone i thought
that menu was crap when i got here now
that it's gone i'm pretty excited to
prepare this food my favorites yeah fish
and chips yeah with homemade tartar
sauce you now can stand proudly and
announce that jax has the best fish and
chips in michigan okay the menu is
incredible i'm excited to actually be a
part of this new restaurant in kitchen
where it's needed big night we're
relaunching jacks tonight and we're
starting afresh people are going to come
back to this place and finally enjoy
coming back to jacks again okay we're
ready don't [ __ ] it up yes
[Applause]
[Music]
with relaunch night upon them jax not
only has a new menu to contend with but
a winter storm as well
cold
this is crazy it's a winter storm but it
hasn't stopped anybody from coming and
these cars are backed up nearly half a
mile now jack is back and if this
doesn't work on relaunch night i'll take
that rope and hang all three of them
over the side unbelievable [ __ ] me it's
cold
[Music]
all right
nice i like that it's to keep kids
entertained i know
this too
you can tie so we can see you can play
that's something that i like yeah
everybody loves the new remodeling we
did so they're having a lot of fun they
did a figure eight
there's no room for error i'm the chef i
need to control my brigade how much i
want my chicken when you answer my
question i'm gonna do my best to be the
strongest chef that i can be here
with customers clearly excited about the
new jacks
the restaurant fills to capacity and the
kitchen faces a monumental test okay
sell me a fish taco
you hear me fish taco how long
[Music]
nice guy
okay i can't talk with nobody listening
come on guys answer him please
fish taco fish taco he's taco
the [ __ ] i'm dying on grill fry here man
with aaron still fighting to get his
staff on board all right so sorry
there's a little bit of a hold up in
there customers who ordered fried food
are getting restless so you know there's
a new look right now we're waiting for
the food but bear with us if it takes a
couple minutes for the food please
how's uh chaperone doing
under a massive stress
yeah losing mine
i got food dying
jesus christ these guys are i'm getting
buried by grill fry i'm not getting any
of their food everybody else's food is
coming up they're burying me
grill fry's getting beaten aj bill i
need him to coordinate with me i need a
fish and chip to sell right now
i can't stress enough that aging he has
40 years plus experience of course i
threw him in the kitchen to help us out
i need two roasted chickens coconut
shrimp
[Music]
coconut shrimps i don't need coconut
shrimps
when aj came back here to help
here's your football here you go
the table numbers are you feeding me aj
table 41.
i want aj i sold 41 like 45 minutes ago
okay never mind [ __ ] man
you have to communicate
you have to communicate
yeah better than that
better than that
i can't even see him behind the [ __ ]
line get a boxing just happening i can't
see his shoulders little [ __ ] hold up
unbelievable 243 customers through the
draw so far aaron's backed up in the
kitchen he's asked for help aj's gone in
there and made it worse if they're not
careful this place can [ __ ] sink
now i will see what's holding up those
appetizers okay thank you
coconut shrimp lead how long you guys
are killing me down there you're
bringing the whole kitchen to an end
you're gonna have to slow the seating
down okay these guys cannot keep up
i'm hearing where's my fries where's my
fish and then i don't hear her it's up
in one minute i'm up in two minutes i
wasn't hearing nothing so i was like
screw that
[Music]
hey don't talk like that give me the
food i asked for i don't need your lips
[Music]
i don't want to hear no damn arguing
back here i hear people screaming at
each other the only person that should
be giving orders back here is aaron
is that understood everybody
[Music]
excuse me did i hear an answer did i
hear a yes
i'd like to hear an answer you guys are
killing me down there you're bringing
the whole kitchen to an end with anarchy
in the kitchen the only person that
should be giving orders back here is
aaron is that understood everybody the
former silent partner decided it was
time to speak up i'd like to hear an
answer
yes sir
all right
that's it
[ __ ] believable scott came back here
and he showed that he gave a [ __ ] you
know where before i'd never see scott
that actually helped me okay let's go
i'm looking for a fish taco
[Music]
there's taco thank you beautiful that's
nice looking food with aaron now finally
controlling his kitchen orders are
getting to the customers a lot quicker
all right i almost have a smile on my
face guys i'm almost smiling
[Music]
keep it going
i'm more importantly you've got clarity
with your [ __ ] brigade i agree
dinner winds down thank you guys there's
a problem with the night's final order
of onion rings that look undercooked way
on the cover
chef aaron clearly follows gordon's
advice and demands quality food and
respect from his staff martini what are
you doing smoking cigarette did you sell
those things those onion rings earlier
so you could go do that no go look at
them they're [ __ ] man all my onion rings
have been beautiful
look at them
don't touch them i was in the bag going
touch up bathroom man touch them i'll
drop them again right now god damn that
[ __ ]
it can't happen good
last table tonight the food has to be
just as good at the end of the night as
it is in the beginning
holding his staff accountable till the
last minute aaron is finally acting like
a head chef
scott
yes good job with what you do with the
kitchen oh thanks
thank you
i feel my partners realize that you know
what i can be
a benefit here enjoy it yeah this helped
me redeem myself to my partners i think
that gordon ramsay saved my friendship
my partnership
and this business
[Music]
only for the first time in this
restaurant
saw each and every one of the owners
working their ass off none of you were
fragmented it was together
we fixed the biggest problem in jax and
that was the food
now you know what it's like to maintain
that
tama what's the most important thing
you've got out of this week i got a
partner
seriously the most important thing i got
a lovely compliment when i first met you
big boy honestly i thought your days
were numbered the rumors the crap and
you've turned it around we know what
we're doing if we put our minds together
and we work together we can fill this
place absolutely right there's only one
thing excuse me
tamara i bill we've all admitted that
you know we kind of put ourselves out
there
aj never admitted to nothing
you know a lot of this was his fault
[Music]
i never said i have no fault and i did
the best i can with all the hours that i
made let me talk for a second
on that exact point
you are here way too much to be
effective i know you think you're
effective we don't think you're
effective at 80 hours a week
aj it would be
the most generous thing
you could do
as a father for his son
to step back
cutting back on the hours
and cutting back on the pay
not a problem yeah
not a problem i hope scott valentimer
will see that the hours i put here were
needed to run the business they probably
will see it
maybe on my deathbed they'll confess it
but not before then
that's hard that with that
i've been agonizing over the
conversation it wasn't a personal thing
at all it was it's needed for him too he
can't be here that many hours it's good
for everybody i can't wait yes to get
back yes we're bringing you to the gym
when you come back
take care gordon thank you
good night guys thank you for everything
keep pumping yes yes sir
after gordon left in the days that
followed bill scott and tamar gave aaron
the full authority to run the kitchen
the menu and the staffing if you have
anybody in here that has to go tonight
you can remove them tonight aaron
immediately fired two cooks and brought
in two experienced sous chefs they don't
know the way it was before
and there will be a new standard side
and the partners realized although it
was difficult they needed a new general
manager to take over jax
and so they fired aj
he let it happen and what is done he did
to himself you're right i can't put it
on me you're right
it just sucks that it is because that's
your dad but you got my support firing
my dad is what i need for this place to
survive
and he's going to back us up on what we
need to do just like any father would
that loves her son
we're now moving in the right direction
we actually finally know what we're
doing i think it's awesome we do three
four nights like this it'll be a breeze
back here thank you gordon this was an
experience of a lifetime
the three of us as owners have never
been as close as we are right now
[Music]
you